In today's video,
we're going to see
what happens if we combine
1,000 silly putty eggs
into one giant blob.
[Music]
Calli, what are we doing today?
I'm putting a lock
on your Amazon account.
Nah, don't be ridiculous.
We have here a little bit
of silly putty,
and when I say a little bit,
I mean the equivalent
of about 1,000 eggs.
You can see we've got
hundreds and hundreds
of the single silly putty eggs,
and we've also got some slightly
larger silly putty eggs.
This is worth just
over 10 smaller ones,
and these big ones are worth
about 40 to 45 smaller
silly putty eggs.
All told, we have almost
exactly 1,000 eggs worth
of silly putty here.
Now, we've done a little bit
with silly putty in the past,
and poured molten gallium
into it to see
if we could make a mold in it,
and no, unfortunately you can't.
The gallium is too heavy,
and it just smooches
the silly putty down.
But we got some other
things going to try.
Here's the basic idea.
We have a thousand
silly putty eggs.
We're going to put them
together, and we're going to see
what we can do with
that much silly putty.
But just clear as all the tables
so we can put the silly
putty on the table,
and really see it
all really nicely.
Let's get work.
So that right there.
The giant ones are actually
both glow in the dark.
So we have a glow
in the dark green,
and glow in the dark yellow.
Yeah.
No, it's already glowing.
Just from the sunlight coming in
through that window.
You see that?
Guys, if anyone can think
of what we can do
with nearly a thousand
silly putty egg containers,
let us know
in the comments below.
Please, we'd love
your suggestions.
We're going to have
so many of these.
[Music]
The new King of Random
Spy Scope Kit is here.
Guys, this kit is amazing.
It allows you to actually build
one of your own little
microscopes at home.
You don't have to worry
about going out
and getting all the parts,
having extra pieces.
Everything is provided for you.
That's right.
It even comes with some cool
slides that you can check out,
and also available are
these little mystery
hidden picture slides.
They've got codes in them.
If you find the codes
and rearrange them,
you can let us know
what code you found,
and get some really cool.
Everything you need for,
the kit comes with it,
and you can just assemble it,
cut all the pieces.
It even has a cool
decorative sticker.
You can slap that on wherever
you think it's necessary.
All the instructions
are included.
Plus, of course,
we've got our video showing you
how to build it,
and some fun things
you can do with it.
You can click the link
in the description below
to go get yours now.
Okay, we've got
all thousand eggs opened up.
Calli's curious what happens
when you bite it?
I know we like to
taste things but...
It's crunchy.
Crunchy?
Bite it.
Let's see if we can get--
I want to see if it glitter light.
This is quite a work out.
Okay, once you mix it, it's--
That's a decent gold.
I am disappointed that it's got
these pieces of glitter,
not because of the color,
but because they leave
these like speckles,
so it's not
perfectly smooth gold.
No, it contaminated
our glow-in-the-dark.
Silly putty bonds
to silly putty.
Except however for
this blob of blue.
For some reason,
this one particular blob.
I squished it together
as much as I could,
and it's still just like yeah...
This color doesn't like
to bond together very much.
So I'm gonna have to work
that for quite a while
before it's all single blob,
instead of lots of blobs, barely
holding themselves together.
Okay.
I've got a bowl
of pretty warm water.
I'm just going to take
a big old blob of this blue.
Throw it in there.
I'll let that sit and warm up,
and see what changes.
So Nate put his silly
putty in hot water.
Let me try and microwave it.
I think it's burning.
No? Okay.
That I wonder.
Oh, no.
This is giving
me war flashbacks,
because you know
what this feels like?
Chewing gum.
This is very soft
and uncomfortably warm,
even if I stop moving like...
Yeah.
It gets the point
where it's burning.
But it is much
softer, stringier.
So this one's probably
won't glow as
much as the other two actual
glow-in-the-dark silly putty's
because I did mix it with gold.
But let's see.
This one is already
glowing just from daylight,
just kind of cool here.
Sort of see that it's brighter.
So if you mix this
with another color,
will it stll glow?
Yeah, I would assume so,
but I want to know
if it glows the less,
or about the same.
All right.
That fades so quickly.
So it's bright,
but only for about
half a second.
Just from the edge of the light.
This one's still glowing.
It's just fascinating.
All right, obviously hold
it's glow much much better.
So if you mix
your silly putty with
a glow-in-the-dark silly putty,
it's not going to be
nearly as effective.
Silly putty from the warm water.
It was just a bowl
of water sitting there.
So it starts to cool
off a little bit.
But for the most part,
I think it warmed up at
least the outside layer
of our silly putty.
This is a big heavy blob of it,
and so I don't think
all the water heated
up all the way through,
but especially in the spot
where it's thinner,
I think it did, you know,
it softened it a little bit.
I think it's a little
bit more malleable.
Pretty minor change.
Oh, it does actually
look a little bit whiter.
I think it almost bleached
out some color maybe.
All right.
I'm going to go ahead and try
and take a few strands
of every color,
and just sort of twist
them together just
'cause want to know
what color we end up with.
[Music]
I'm assuming they
look like a mess.
First, a rainbow,
and then I'm a mess.
My vote is on ugly
brownish grayish.
All right, so...
[Music]
This reminds me of one
of those little clicky pens,
where you can like choose
what color you want
to use in your pen.
Kind of fun.
[Music]
Okay before I mix
it any further,
I want to cut that in half.
[Music]
That's pretty.
It's kinda like
when you make beads with clay.
So my hope is
that we're going to see glow
in the dark streaks in this.
[Music]
That's awesome.
I like that.
This is for you.
What is that thing?
It's a morph.
Morph.
A very badly done Morph.
But you know...
Silly putty, one of
the most well-known things
about it is the fact that,
especially if you get it
into a ball shape,
it's quite bouncy.
It's a very rubbery substance.
Sometimes, it just
bounces away from you.
So we want to do a test to see
how much a large blob
of it bounces in comparison
to a small blob.
So we're going to try dropping
them both from the same height,
just off the table,
see which one comes
back up higher.
It's actually pretty similar.
[Music]
All right, starting
with the small one here.
Just going to chuck
it at the ground.
Let's say that
went 12-15 feet up.
Little hard to control.
It's not perfectly round.
Let's try the big one though.
Here it goes.
I'm gonna start throwing
it fairly gently.
Wow.
Quite a rebound.
[Music]
It's got some good bounce.
Got a little deformation here.
I'm not sure exactly
what caused that.
[Music]
One of the classic tricks
I was always taught
with silly putty is
that you can use it to sort
of make a copy of newspapers.
The ink comes off fairly easily,
and the silly putty supposed
to be able to pick it up.
So let's try a little
small-scale tests here.
Just a little piece
of the comics here,
and just smoosh this down there.
Look at that.
Picture perfect.
[Music]
Here it goes.
That is perfect.
Photocopy in reverse.
But an entire sheet.
[Music]
Going to wrap some gold
around that mess.
[Music]
That was very effective.
Yeah.
Fortunately, its own weight
is sort of driving it down.
Wow, it is.
Oh my gosh.
How much does this weigh?
So one silly putty egg is
approximately 0.37 ounces,
and we have approximately 1,000
silly putty eggs worth together.
That should give us a total
of almost 25 pounds.
So Nate got to bounce
the green silly putty.
I think it's my turn.
3, 2, 1.
It bounces.
That's awesome.
Wait, we're going to slam it.
Work out.
Okay, you roll that one.
Yeah.
What was that?
I just wanted to see
what it would do
if it was spinning.
Got my nearly 25 pound ball.
I'm gonna see what happens
if I stand on it.
And I'll be here
providing support.
Stabilization.
Both mental and physical.
Oh, very nice.
Watch your head.
You're very tall.
I'm sinking.
[Music]
Here, I've probably
just gotten a lot
of dirt into the silly putty.
And possibly a lot
of silly putty
into the threads of my shoes.
Oh, no.
Are you--
Are you stuck?
No, I can get it out.
It just takes
a determined effort.
That's a very clear shoe print.
And now, this silly putty
will be on the floor forever.
Okay.
I've got a little
sledgehammer here,
and I've got all
of our silly putty.
I flipped it over so
my shoe prints are still
on the other side.
Let's see what the hammer does.
[Music]
It's doing less damage
than your shoes did.
I think it's just the quick impact.
It's just so bouncy that way.
Boink.
See if I just set it here,
leave it for a second,
then it leaves an imprint.
But if I hit,
like there's almost nothing.
Oh, there's dust.
Nate, what are you doing?
I'm gonna test
the impact resistance.
I mean, it's bouncing
and it hurts a lot less
than if I hit my hand directly.
I mean, it doesn't hurt,
but it's not really
anything amazing.
Like it bounces off,
but I'm definitely still
feeling it on my hand.
All right, if he did it,
I've got to do it.
Nope.
>> No.
>> Really?
Yeah.
No, not all.
I'm assuming.
I mean, now,
you're attempting,
but no, nothing.
He's hitting right
on top of my metatarsals.
So I should be able to feel
that across the bridge
of my foot.
I don't.
The only part of my foot
that hurts is
the ball of my foot,
where it's impacting
with the tile itself.
That's it.
Like you can feel the bounce,
but you wouldn't even know that
you're really being impacted.
That's bizarre.
Guys, we have a ton
of silly putty left.
We obviously didn't really
destroy any of it.
So where would it have gone.
But we would love
to hear your ideas.
What should we do
with 25 pounds of silly putty?
This is a lot.
Let us know down
in the comments,
we want your ideas.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
The box at the top takes you
directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube think you
should be watching next.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to the channel, that way,
you never miss a cool video.
And especially, you're gonna
want to hit that bell so you get
the notifications about it.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.